a long story in the wall street journal
which uh
taylor lorenz actually tweeted and she
tweeted with the caption
the ban air conditioning movement is
growing
headline employers beware people who
once put up with thermostats
set to deep freeze now want the kind of
climate control they had working from
home
the article goes on public health nurse
becky graham brought a suitcase of
winter clothes from minnesota to a
springtime conference in atlanta where
it was 80 degrees
miss graham said i have a tank top a
long sleeve shirt and a sweatshirt on
and jeans and i'm still cold
she lent what layers she could spare to
those who arrived ill-suited for the
deep chill of conference room conference
rooms in atlanta's convention center
for two years people who worked from
home could fine-tune thermostats to
their liking as they head back to the
offices many are lamenting the loss of
control over their workday environment
i got to tell you this article goes on
for pages
with uh all of these sob stories from
people
complaining that it's too cold in the
office now they have to go back to work
because they've been working from home
now they go back to work and it's cold
because of the evil air conditionings
now the article doesn't actually call
for banning air conditioning
but it is part of this anti-air
conditioning genre that exists and i
have to tell you the anti-ac movement
i think we've talked about this before i
don't think we talk about it enough
though it is barbaric really it is pure
barbarism
every summer we have to go through this
so let's just review it again
first of all if you want to ban ac
if you are anti-air conditioning
to any extent at all
then you are anti-human
because air conditioning is without
exaggeration one of the top five maybe
top three human inventions of all time
it competes with the printing press i
think it may actually come before it
it's hard to think of any individual
innovation and you could challenge me on
this
any individual invention innovation that
has so helped to increase human health
happiness and well-being more than air
conditioning has
before the world had air conditioning
you know what people did they just
suffered in the heat okay it was hot and
sticky and it smelled and it was gross
and it was sweaty and it was filthy and
it was horrible much like los angeles is
now but even in los angeles you can
still go inside and enjoy the air
conditioning
um before the looters come in or someone
comes in and robs you at gunpoint but
before then you can have the air
conditioning it saves lives
this is why we owe it to air
conditioning and to our forefathers who
gave us this great blessing
to blast it as much as we can in the
summer i mean just blast it it should be
it should be warmer in your refrigerator
than it is in your house and in your
office if you're too cold wear a sweater
because we always have to remind people
if you're too cold you can always put on
more layers you could wear a whole snow
suit if you want you know if you build
an igloo in the office if you need to
you can do anything
but if you're hot there's only so many
layers you can take off before hr gets
involved before the police get involved
um
so i'm glad we could establish this once
again
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
that wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts